donc on soir à linthal merci de répondre
à nos questions sur rt france ce soir
comment s'est passée cette rentrée dans
votre établissement entre minute de
silence et protocoles sanitaires
renforcés
bonsoir c'est compliqué parce qu'on ne
sait pas par quoi commencer on accueille
les enfants en général donc le lundi
matin avec caen s'est tu quand c'est la
rentrée en général je prends le temps
avec eux deux de discuter de ce qui
s'est passé pendant les vacances de ce
qu'ils ont vécu et un petit quoi de neuf
et puis là effectivement qu'on ne savait
pas par quoi commencer on d'habitude
raconte les vacances mais là il s'est
passé tellement de choses donc à la fois
des enfants qui qui ont dû rentrer de
vacances passent évidemment il ya des
enfants qui ont évoqué évidemment les
différents attentats qui ont eu lieu
et puis surtout il fallait il fallait
rapidement et parler de parler du masque
que voilà concrètement le protocole le
nouveau protocole à n'a quasiment pas
changé à la seule modification
c'est effectivement le port du masque à
partir de 6 ans le reste c'est vraiment
des choses qui étaient plus ou moins
déjà en place qui sont un peu plus un
peu renforcé mais mais à peine
donc il a fallu évoquer sa qui vient
bien sûr au total sanitaire n'est pas
renforcée selon beau en dehors en
primaire en dehors du port du masque il
ya rien nouveau pain est ce que vous
attendez à des annonces justement pour
renforcer ce protocole sanitaire
on les attend de ces annonces parce que
là actuellement je vous donne un exemple
tout simple un dans mon école les
enfants on fait attention à ce qu'ils
aient plus de brassage donc on s'arrange
pour que pourrait partir dans la cour
pour faire de récréation il pour que les
enfants et au même endroit dans la cour
de récréation
mais une fois qu'ils arrivent à la
cantine pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
protocole ou qu'ils arrivent à la
cantine ils enlèvent leurs masques ils
sont mélangés entre classes donc un
brassage il ya absolument ça change
complètement ça change rien s'il ya un
enfant qui est positif et à ce moment là
est asymptomatique qu'on ne sait pas il
contamine les autres
à ce moment là il leur enlever son
masque il ya rien qui pour l'instant qui
n'empêche pas ce que je décris dans mon
école c'est ce qui se passe dans les
normes allemandes école puisque nous
façon on nous a imposé ce nouveau
protocole dès la rentrée sans avoir eu
la possibilité d'avoir au moins une
journée pour réfléchir avec les
collectivités locales à pitre quatre
chambres ce protocole notamment pour
tous les temps périscolaires
mais aussi dans l'est dans l'est dans
les classes donc on est enfin de façon
le pp et l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales du monde enseignant ont
reproché l'impréparation de cette
rentrée vraiment le justement le snes
fsu a annoncé avoir déposé un préavis de
grève
jusqu'au 7 novembre quelles sont les
revendications des syndicats enseignants
qu'est-ce qu'est ce que vous demandez
concrètement alors le snes fsu a
effectivement appelé à la grève dès
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs donc le set a
fait sucer c'est le second degré et moi
je suis représentant du snui pp du
premier degré ce n'est pas exactement la
même chose mais les enseignants du
premier degré ont lancé une alerte
sociale donc à six organisations
syndicales représentatives des
enseignants qui ont lancé des valeurs
sociales et on attend des réponses du
ministère et les réponses qu'on attend
c'est pas seulement les masques c'est
dans ma classe de cm1-cm2 g29 elle la
distanciation social est absolument
impossible
le port du masque pour des élèves de 9
10 ans il est envisageable à 6,7 en sait
déjà beaucoup plus compliqué il faut
savoir quelque chose c'est que les
enfants qui sont dues ce matin ils ont
souvent des masques adultes qui sont
trop grands ils le perdent ils n'ont pas
l'habitude le porter au bout de quelques
heures salle épingle quelques heures
salle et ça les blagues pourries donc il
faut aussi que l'école leur fournisse
des masques des diatribes donc ils sont
adaptés à leur taille pour l'instant ce
n'est pas le cas on attend toujours les
masques inclusif vous rappelez ont parlé
des masques inclusive pour les élèves en
situation de handicap mais aussi pour
les élèves en maternelle un pour les
enseignants
on les attend toujours pour l'instant
n'avons pas les deux masques inclusif
on nous a dit qu'il était arrivé mais on
les a toujours pas il nous reste pas
beaucoup de temps je fais je suis désolé
mais mais on n'avait que c'est une
rentrée très particulière le conseil
scientifique alerte sur un hiver avec
plusieurs vagues potentiel de malades du
coronavirus du coup comment s'annoncent
les semaines à venir dans quel état
d'esprit sont les enseignants les élèves
et même les parents nous hosni pépé et
des enseignants souhaitent que les
écoles restent ouvertes longtemps
possible parce que l'école à distance
n'est pas efficace par exemple donc on
souhaite que ça reste ouvert mais pas
dans ces conditions là il faut
probablement réduire le nombre d'élèves
par classe pour permettre à
distanciation sociale et pour limiter le
brassage donc nous ce qu'on espère c'est
que les écoles restent ouvertes les
collèges et lycées restent ouverts à
condition effectivement que les enfants
puissent le faire dans les cônes dans
des situations d'une situation sanitaire
qui les mettent pas en péril qui mettent
pas en danger
merci et les chiffres sont pas sont par
action effectivement merci à l'intérêt
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes en scène
eco secrétaire du syndicat snuipp-fsu du
nord